Dakota Johnson and Chris Martin are  dating it's a special moment a source  tells ET the 28 year-old accuracy and 40  year-old Coldplay frontman have been  dating for at least two months according  to the source they spend most nights  hanging out at his house and laying low  and get this the source added quote his  friends already love her and see how  happy she makes him I feel really lucky  to be in this position and I'm excited  rumors about the pair first started  swirling last month after they were  reportedly spotted together at Nick  caves concert in Israel as for their  dating history Chris was previously  linked to Jennifer Lawrence and was  married to gwyneth paltrow for 13 years  they share two kids meanwhile Dakota was  rumored to a dated last-man-standing  actor Jordan Masterson and musician  Matthew hits  [Music]  you